MR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. A OF
GIL. ARCHULETA. ASHBY. ATKINS.
BECKER. BLAKESPEAR BRADFORD.
CABALLERO. CORTEZ. DALLY. DODD.
BARAO. Tð GLASER. AS ALWAYS.
GROVE. HURTADO. JONES. LAYERED
LEMON. MAGUIRE. MENJIVAR. MEN.
NEWMAN. WHEN NEO. DEAL. PINO.
ROCK. R. THEY ARE TO SKINNER.
SMALL CUEVAS. STERN. HUMBERG W.
WIENER. WELL. MEMBERS. A QUORUM
IS PRESENT. WOULD THE MEMBERS
AND OUR GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL
AND IN THE GALLERY? PLEASE RISE.
WE WILL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
AFTERNOON BY OUR CHAPLAIN,
SISTER MICHELLE GORMAN, AFTER
WHICH PLEASE REMAIN STANDING FOR
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO OUR
FLAG. SO LET US PRAY TODAY, IN
THE WORDS OF MAYA ANGELOU.
FATHER, MOTHER GOD. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PRESENCE DURING THE
HARD AND MEAN DAYS. THEN WE HAVE
YOU TO LEAN UPON. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENCE DURING THE BRIGHT
AND SUNNY DAYS. FOR THEN WE CAN
SHARE THAT WHICH WE HAVE WITH
THOSE WHO HAVE LESS. AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PRESENCE DURING THE
HOLY DAYS. BUT THEN WE ARE ABLE
TO CELEBRATE YOU AND OUR
FAMILIES AND OUR FRIENDS. FOR
THOSE WHO HAVE NÓ VOICE, WE ASK
YOU TO SPEAK. THOSE WHO FEEL
UNWORTHY. WE ASK YOU TO POUR OUT
YOUR LOVE AND WATERFALLS OF
TENDERNESS. FOR THOSE WHO LIVE
IN PAIN. WE ASK YOU TO BATHE
THEM IN THE RIVER OF YOUR
HEALING. FOR THOSE WHO ARE
LONELY. WE ASK YOU TO KEEP THEM
COMPANY. FOR THOSE WHO ARE
DEPRESSED. WE ASK YOU TO SHOWER
UPON THEM THE LIGHT OF YOUR
HOPE. THEIR CREATOR YOU THE
BORDERLESS SEA OF SUBSTANCE. WE
ASK YOU TO GIVE TO ALL THE WORLD
THAT WHICH WE NEED MOST PEACE.
AMEN. MEMBERS. PLEASE JOIN ME IN
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE.
STATES OF AMERICA. OH,
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR. THERE
ARE NONE. MESSENGERS FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED RED.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED RED. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. MEMBERS
ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO MOTIONS,
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES. AND IF
I COULD ASK YOU TO PLEASE STOP
YOUR CHATTER ON THE FLOOR. IF
YOU WANT TO SPEAK, PLEASE GO TO
THE BACK. IT'S REALLY
DISTRACTING UP HERE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. THE SENATE JOURNALS
FOR FEBRUARY 1220 24 THROUGH
FEBRUARY 16TH 2024 WILL BE
APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK. MEMBERS ARE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO CONSIDERATION OF
THE DAILY FILE. FIRST UP IS THE
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENT. FILE
ITEM NUMBER THREE. SENATOR
GROVE. THANK YOU, MADAM.
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE AS A CONFIRMATION
OF THE FOLLOWING APPOINTMENTS,
UH, JUNE KI¾M LOPEZ, KEVIN
MCGOWAN AND, UH DOCTOR MEYER
MOYER. MOKO EXCUSE ME, MEMOTO
FOR THE SEISMIC SAFETY
COMMISSION. UM MIGUEL GALARZA.
AMANDA GARRO, JAMES RUIN FOR THE
CONTRACTOR, STATE LICENSE BOARD
AND èC R SHAPIRO FOR THE
APPOINTMENT TO THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION COMMISSION ON
DISABILITY ACCESS. THEY WERE
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON FEBRUARY 14TH AS A 50 VOTE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I VOTE.
PLEASE APOLOGIZE IF I MUTILATED
ANYBODY'S NAME. FOR ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM, ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE?
SAYING NONE. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN AYE, I VOTED YOU. HØI
ARCH. HØI ASHBY. I. ATKINS.
BECKER. I BLAKESPEAR BRADFORD.
CABALLERO. HØI CORTESI. AYE,
DALLY. HØI DODD. HØI THE RAZZO
I, EDMUND. GLASER. HØI GONZALEZ.
HØI GROWTH. AYE, HURTADO. HØI
JONES. BY LAIRD. AYE, LIONE.
AYE, MCGUIRE. I MIND JAR I MIN
BY NEWMAN. I WIN. HØI NILO.
PATRO OAK. AYE PAD. FOR FORTINO.
AYE, ROTH. I RUBIO. AYE. èC R
TO IY SKINNER. HØI SMALL CUEVAS.
HØI STERN. AYE. HUMBERG HØI
WILL. AYE. WIENER. I WILL. I
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ATKINS. BLAKESPEAR BRADFORD.
AYE. NILO. A DEAL. SENATOR GROVE
MOVES THE CALL. MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE. SENATOR
GROVE IS READY. THANK YOU AGAIN,
MADAM PRESIDENT. THE
CONFIRMATION FOR RONALD FIORE,
UH, TO THE APPOINTMENT OF THE
STATE ATHLETIC COMMISSION. HE'S
THE FOUNDING PARTNER OF
GUARANTEE MORTGAGE, THE
PRESIDENT OF FIORE COMPANY AND
ALSO LEADS A FIORE FAMILY
FOUNDATION, WHICH PROMOTES YOUTH
SPORTS TO UNDERSERVED COMPU
COMMUNITIES. HE WAS APPROVED BY
THE RULES COMMITTEE ON FEBRUARY
14 A UNANIMOUS VOTE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN I VOTE. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? SEE NON
POLICE CALL THE ROLL. A. HØI I
WROTE AGAIN? AYE, ARCHULETA. HØI
ASHBY. HØI ATKINS. BECKER. AYE,
BLAKESPEAR. BRADFORD. BY
CABALLERO. CORTEZ. IY DALLY.
AYE. GOD. I DURAZO. AYE. EGM. IY
GLASER. AYE, GONZALEZ. I GROVE.
BY HER DAUGHTER. I JONES. BY
LAIRD. AYE. LI. AYE, MCGUIRE.
AYE. MINAR. AYE. MEN. AYE.
NEWMAN A WIN. HØI NILO. AYE. PER
DIEM. YOU KNOW? HØI ROTH. BY
RUBIO. AYE. SAY ART TO I.
SKINNER. AYE SMALL QUAVERS. I
STERN. I HUMBERG AYE WILL HAVE
HØI WIENER. AYE. HØI WE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS.
BLAKESPEAR NEW YORK. CENTER
GROWTH MOVES THE CALL MEMBERS
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
UNFINISHED BUSINESS. START WITH
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN. SENATOR
DODD. HE IS PREPARED. PLEASE
READ. THEN BILL 260 THREE, BUT
BY SENATOR DODD AND A RELATING
TO INSURANCE SENATOR DODD. THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS S¼ B 260 THREE
PERTAINING TO THE SALE OF
ANNUITIES IS BACK FROM THE
ASSEMBLY AND I RISE TO REQUEST
THE SENATE CONC OCCUR. THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS. THE BILL
CONFORMS. THE CALIFORNIA LAW
WITH THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
INSURANCE COMMISSIONERS NEW
MODEL REGULATION, WHICH PROTECTS
CONSUMERS WHEN PURCHASING AN
ANNUITY PRODUCT FROM INSURANCE
AGENT ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ENSURE
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
MAINTAINS ENFORCEMENT OVER
ANNUITY SALES. IT MODIFIES
TRAINING REQUIREMENTS AND TIMING
FOR PRODUCERS. IT MODIFIES
PRODUCER DISCLOSURE OBLIGATIONS
AND CLARIFIES PROVISIONS TO
ENSURE PRODUCER SERVES THE
CLIENT'S BEST INTEREST AT ALL
TIMES. THERE HAVE BEEN NÓ NÓ
VOTES ON THIS BILL IN EITHER
HOUSE. RESPECTFULLY ASK, UH, IN
REQUEST THE SENATE CONC OCCUR.
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS. THANK
YOU. THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? SAYING
NONE. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. HØI OF YOU. AYE,
ARCHULETTA. I ASHBY. I ATKINS.
BY BECKER. HØI BLAKESPEAR.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. UH,
CORTEZ. AYE, DALLY. AYE. GOD. I
DO RAZO. EGM. GLAZER. HØI
GONZALEZ. GROVE. I HØI JONES. I
LAYERED AYE, LIMÓN. AYE,
MCGUIRE. AYE. BIN OF OUR HØI
MEN. I NEWMAN AYE. WIN. HØI NEW
LOW. HØI FORINO. HØI ROTH. I
RUBIO. I SAY ARE TO IY SKINNER.
AYE. SMALL CUEVAS STERN. AYE.
BLUMBERG. AYE. WILL HAVE WEINER.
AYE. WELCOME. AYE. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BLAKESPEAR
RAZO. EGM. AYE. NEW LOW. A DEAL.
WILL HAVE. SENATOR DODD MOVES
THE CALL. MEMBERS ARE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO THE SENATE. THIRD
READING FILE ITEM NUMBER 19,
SENATOR MIN. IS PREPARED. PLEASE
READ. SENATE RESOLUTION. 61 BY
SENATOR MIN RELATIVE TO JAPANESE
AMERICAN CONCENTRATION CAMPS.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT AND
SENATORS ON BEHALF OF THE ASIAN
AMERICAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDER
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS. I'M HONORED
TO PRESENT S¼ R 61 TO RECOGNIZE
FEBRUARY 19TH 2024 AS JAPANESE
AMERICAN DAY OF REMEMBRANCE.
THIS DAY IS OBSERVED ON FEBRUARY
19 TO SIGNIFY THE DATE THAT
PRESIDENT FRANKLIN DELANO
ROOSEVELT SIGNED EXECUTIVE ORDER
9066 IN 1942 DURING THE MIDST OF
WORLD WAR TWO. ALTHOUGH
EXECUTIVE ORDER 9066 DID NOT
IDENTIFY ANY SPECIFIC GROUPS, IT
WAS LATER USED. IT WAS CREATED
TO FORCIBLY REMOVE INDIVIDUALS
DEEMED AS A NATIONAL THREAT FROM
THE WEST COAST AND WAS LATER
USED TO FORCE THE INTERNMENT OF
JAPANESE AMERICANS. AH, THIS WAS
OBVIOUSLY AN OVERACTIVE RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION AND STEREOTYPING
FOLLOWING THE ATTACKS ON PEARL
HARBOR AND LED TO THE INTERNMENT
OF 120,000, JAPANESE AMERICANS,
THE DEATH OF 1600 IMPRISONED
INDIVIDUALS AND THE LOSS OF
PROPERTY BUSINESSES AND
LIVELIHOODS, INCLUDING IN MY
DISTRICT, UH, IN TOWNS LIKE
HUNTINGTON BEACH AND NEWPORT
BEACH AND LAGUNA BEACH. DESPITE
THE INTERMENTS OF THEIR
FAMILIES, THOUSANDS OF JAPANESE
AMERICAN VETERANS SERVED IN THE
UNITED STATES MILITARY DURING
THAT CONFLICT. AND IN 2010. MANY
YEARS LATER, PRESIDENT OBAMA
RECOGNIZED THE SERVICE SERVICE
OF THE 100TH INFANTRY BATTALION
AND 442ND REGIMENTAL COMBAT TEAM
WITH THE CONGRESSIONAL GOLD
MEDAL. IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO
REMEMBER AND REFLECT ON THE FACT
THAT A POLICY ENACTED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ACTIVELY
TARGETED PEOPLE OF COLOR PEOPLE
IN THE A API COMMUNITY, CAUSING
SERIOUS HARM IN GENERATIONAL
TRAUMA. AND WE DO NEED TO
REMEMBER THIS AND ENSURE THAT IT
NEVER HAPPENS AGAIN. AT A TIME
WHEN ANTI ASIAN HATE IS
UNFORTUNATELY ON THE RISE AT A
TIME WHEN WE HAVE A FORMER
PRESIDENT, ONE OF THE TWO MAJOR
POLITICAL CANDIDATES FOR
PRESIDENT IN 2024 OPENLY TALKING
ABOUT PUTTING PEOPLE INTO
CONCENTRATION CAMPS. UH WE MUST
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE VIGILANT
TO ENSURE THAT THIS TYPE OF
THING NEVER HAPPENS AGAIN. AND
IF WE GO BACK IN TIME TO 1942.
THE SAD THING IS THAT SO MANY
UH, PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS, PEOPLE
THAT WE WOULD THINK OF AS
HONORABLE, UH, SUPPORTED THIS OR
LOOK THE OTHER WAY. THE SUPREME
COURT AND THE KATSU DECISION
APPROVED THE INTERMENT OF
JAPANESE PEOPLE. JAPANESE
AMERICANS. SO MANY CALIFORNIANS
LOOK THE OTHER WAY AS JAPANESE
PEOPLE WERE DISPLACED FROM THEIR
HOMES, LOST THEIR PROPERTY AND
FORCED INTO THESE CAMPS SO IT
CAN HAPPEN HERE. IT CAN HAPPEN
AGAIN. AND I. I URGE YOU ALL TO
VOTE FOR THIS, UH AND ALSO TO
REMAIN VIGILANT GOING FORWARD. I
HOPE EVERYONE WILL HONOR THOSE
IMPACTED BY THE INCARCERATION OF
THE JAPANESE AMERICAN. SO MANY
YEARS AGO BY VOTING AYE ON S¼ R
61. THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM? ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE, SENATOR
BRADFORD. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. UM I'M HONORED TO
STAND HERE AS VICE CHAIR OF THE
BLACK CAUCUS AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THAT'S OUR 61 RECOGNIZING
FEBRUARY 19TH AS THE DAY OF
REMEMBRANCE FOR THE
INCARCERATION AND INTERNMENT OF
U S¼, UNITED STATES CITIZENS
BECAUSE OF THEIR AN ANCESTRY OF
BEING JAPANESE. ON THIS DAY,
PRESIDENT FRANKLIN DELANO
ROOSEVELT ROOSEVELT SIGNED
EXECUTIVE ORDER 9066 WITH
INCARCERATED OVER 100 AND 20,000
. JAPANESE AMERICANS, MOSTLY U
S¼ CITIZENS FOR NÓ OTHER REASON
THAN THEIR RACIAL THIS WAS
UNJUSTLY THEY WERE UNJUSTLY
DETAINED, PLACED IN PRISON CAMPS
AND DEPRIVED OF THEIR FREEDOM
AND LIVELIHOOD. THEY LOST THEIR
HOMES, THEIR JOBS, THEIR
BUSINESSES AND THEIR ENTIRE WAY
OF LIFE. BUT MANY ARE UNAWARE OF
BROWNSVILLE. MANY PEOPLE DON'T
REALIZE THAT MANY OF THE, UH UH,
JAPANESE AMERICANS WHO WERE
DISPLACED IN DOWNTOWN L A. IT
WAS AFRICAN AMERICANS WHO CAME
IN TO MAINTAIN NOT ONLY THEIR
HOMES, THEIR BUSINESSES AND MUCH
OF WHAT THEY CHERISHED, UH, WHEN
, UH, THE RESIDENTS BELOW TOKYO
WERE DISPLACED AFRICAN AMERICANS
CAME IN ME AND THEM, UH, CAME
FROM THE SOUTH TO WORK IN THE
DEFENSE INDUSTRY. BUT DUE TO
HOUSING RESTRICTIONS, THERE WERE
VERY FEW PLACES WHERE THEY WERE
ALLOWED TO LIVE. LITTLE TOKYO
BECAME A TEMPORARY HOME AND IT
BECAME KNOWN THE NEW BY THEIR
NEW NAME AS BROWNSVILLE. BLACK
OWNED BUSINESSES, CHURCHES AND
FAMILIES THRIVED IN THE AREA.
BUT WHEN THE WAR ENDED, AND THE
JAPANESE AMERICANS RETURNED TO
TRANSITION WAS BACK TO LITTLE
CO, UH, TOKYO, THOSE AFRICAN
AMERICANS QUICKLY TURNED OVER
THOSE HOMES. THOSE BUSINESSES
BACK TO THE RIGHTFUL OWNERS AND
CONTINUE TO WORK IN CONJUNCTION
TO BUILD THAT COMMUNITY, MANY IN
THE NEWLY, UH REESTABLISHED
JAPANESE AMERICAN BUSINESSES
HIRED BLACK WORKERS. BOTH BOTH
GROUPS SAW THE COMMON TIES OF
RACIAL DISCRIMINATION AND
RESILIENCE THAT BONDED THEM
TOGETHER. VERY LITTLE REMAINS.
THAT WOULD EVEN TELL YOU ABOUT
THE CHAPTER IN LOS ANGELES OR U
S¼ HISTORY FOR THE JAPANESE
AMERICANS WHO CAME BACK HOME. IT
TOOK 40 YEARS FOR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO FORMALLY APOLOGIZE
AND PAY REPARATIONS TO THOSE
HARMED OR TO THOSE DESCENDANTS
THAT WERE DISPLACED. IT IS WAS.
IT WAS A DEBT THAT WAS PAID LATE
BUT PAID NONETHELESS, AS
CALIFORNIA'S TO BEGIN TO
CONSIDER REPARATIONS FOR ANOTHER
GREAT HARM. WE CAN LOOK AT HOW
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS DONE
AS AN EXAMPLE OF HOW CALIFORNIA
CAN LEAD TO NATION AND REPAIRING
THE HARMS CAUSED BY SLAVERY AND
RACIAL DISCRIMINATION IN THE
STATE. AND IN THIS COUNTRY. THE
DAY WE FOCUS ON THE ENORMOUS
INJUSTICES INFLICTED ON JAPANESE
AMERICANS AS AN INDIVIDUAL WHO
GREW UP IN GARDENA IN A PRI,
PREDOMINANTLY JAPANESE TOWN. I
GREW UP WITH MANY OF THOSE FOLKS
WHO PARENTS WERE INTERNED AS
KIDS OR AS YOUNG ADULTS. UH,
MANY WHO WERE PART OF NÓ NOS.
THE ONES WHO WOULD NOT, UH UH,
DENY THEIR HERITAGE TO JAPAN,
UH, JAPAN, AND ALSO MANY OF THAT
FOUGHT IN THE 442 BETTER KNOWN
AS GO FOR BROKE, SO I HAVE A
CLOSE TIE AND A CR CLOSE
AFFINITY FOR THIS COMMUNITY. AND
I RESPECTFULLY THAT WE ASK FOR I
VOTE ON S¼ R 61. SENATOR
MENJIVAR. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES. I STAND
TODAY AS A MEMBER WHO REPRESENTS
AN AREA THAT UNFORTUNATELY
PLAYED A PART IN THIS DARK
HISTORY IN DARK PART OF OUR
HISTORY IN MY DISTRICT LIED, UH,
A JAPANESE INTERNMENT CAMP
CALLED THE TUNA CANON DETENTION
CENTER THAT HELD THE CAPACITY OF
THREE 100 MEN WERE WERE JAPANESE
AMERICANS WERE DETAINED FROM
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA PUT INTO
THIS CAMP, AND THEN AFTER WEEKS
OR MONTHS, WE TRANSFERRED TO
DIFFERENT CAMPS FROM ACROSS AND
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES WITH
BLACKOUT WINDOWS. RECENTLY
LEARNED ABOUT THIS UNFORTUNATE
HISTORY. UM THAT IS PART OF THE
DISTRICT THAT I REPRESENT, AND
THE WORK THAT WE'RE DOING TO
ENSURE THAT WE PROVIDE
REPARATIONS. WE CONTINUE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE NEGATIVE PART OF
OUR HISTORY. BUT NEVER FORGET.
NEVER FORGET IT WITHOUT I ASKED
FOR AN I VOTE WITH US FOR S¼ R
61. SENATOR WAHHAB. THANK YOU.
UM I RISE TODAY TO ALSO SUPPORT
S¼ R 61 AS A REPRESENTATIVE OF
THE SAN JOSE AREA AS WELL AS IN
THE BAY AREA. WE YOU KNOW, OFTEN
SOMETIMES DON'T REALIZE WHAT IT
IMPACTS CERTAIN COMMUNITIES MAKE
IN OUR ENTIRE DISTRICT AND SAN
JOSE HAS A JAPAN TOWN THAT BOTH,
UM THE SENATOR FROM SAN JOSE
ALSO REPRESENTS, UH, WE SPLIT
IT. IT'S ONE OF THREE HISTORICAL
, UM, SITES IN CALIFORNIA IN
PARTICULAR. AND ON THIS DAY IN
1942 PRESIDENT ROOSEVELT SIGNED
EXECUTIVE ORDER 966, RESULTING
IN THE REMOVAL OF CIVILIANS FROM
MILITARY ZONES IN WASHINGTON. IN
CALIFORNIA DURING WORLD WAR TWO
AND WE OFTEN TALK ABOUT, YOU
KNOW, NOT REPEATING HISTORY, AND
YET WE OFTEN SEE THAT WE
CONTINUE TO REPEAT HISTORY. UM,
AS THE SENATORS BEFORE ME HAVE
SPOKEN ABOUT. WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT SLAVERY WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
, UM YOU KNOW WHAT WE HAVE DONE
WITH THE JAPANESE, UH, COMMUNITY
AS WELL AS WHAT WE ARE DOING
TODAY AND SILENCING VOICES THAT
ARE IN OPPOSITION TO A POLICY OR
TO AN ISSUE OR REPRESENT A
COMMUNITY THAT IS MISUNDERSTOOD.
WE NEED TO RISE EVERY SINGLE DAY
UNITED AND CELEBRATE OUR
DIVERSITY. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN EYE AND I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE THE SENATOR FOR
BRINGING S¼ R 61. AMERICAN
REMEMBRANCE DAY TO THE FLOOR.
SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF THE SENATE. UH, TODAY I RISE
ON BEHALF OF THE LATINO CAUCUS.
IT IS MY HONOR TO RISE TO
SUPPORT S¼ R 61. THE INTERNMENT
OF MORE THAN 120,000, AMERICAN
JAPANESE. IS SOMETHING THAT
SHOULD NOT HAVE HAPPENED, AND
IT'S ONE OF THE DARKEST MOMENTS
IN OUR NATION'S HISTORY. THIS
INCARCERATION FLEW IN THE FACE
OF OUR NATION'S LAWS AND MORALS
AND WHO WE ARE AS PEOPLE. IT
COST MANY THEIR HOMES, THEIR
NEIGHBORS, THEIR FAMILIES, THEIR
BUSINESSES THEIR CAREERS. TODAY
I WANNA SPEAK ON BEHALF OF A
VERY, VERY CLOSE FRIEND WHOSE
GRANDMOTHER WAS BORN IN CACTI
CAPTIVITY. UM HER GRANDMOTHER
NEVER RECOVERED AND SHE SPEAKS
OF IT AS NOT JUST THAT MOMENT IN
HISTORY. SHE SPEAKS OF IT AS
GENERATIONAL TRAUMA. NOT ONLY
HER GRANDMOTHER, HER MOTHER DOWN
TO THE GRANDCHILDREN ARE STILL
DEALING WITH THAT TRAUMA. THAT
UH, WAS HORRIFIC. AND UM, NEVER
SAW A RESOLUTION AND THEY
CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE WITH IT.
AND SO TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
LATINO CAUCUS, I WANNA SAY THAT
WE STAND AND STRONG SOLIDARITY
WITH, UH, SENATOR MEN. UH THE
SENATOR FROM IRVINE AND BRINGING
THIS RESOLUTION FORWARD MEMBERS
TODAY IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
REMEMBER WHAT WAS DONE TO OUR
FRIENDS, OUR NEIGHBORS IN THE
NAME OF SAFETY AND SECURITY, AND
WE MUST NEVER REPEAT THAT AGAIN.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN SUPPORTING
THIS IMPORTANT RESOLUTION AND
REMEMBERING ALL THOSE WHO
SUFFERED IN THE NAME OF OUR
NATIONS. SECURITY. THANK YOU.
SENATOR ALLEN. MEMBERS. I WANT
TO ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH ALL THE
COMMENTS MADE I. I JUST WANTED
TO TAKE A MOMENT TO HIGHLIGHT
THE REALLY EXTRAORDINARY
EDUCATIONAL WORK IN THIS SPACE
DONE BY TWO VERY IMPORTANT SITES
HERE IN CALIFORNIA ONE THE
JAPANESE AMERICAN NATIONAL
MUSEUM IN DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES,
UH, THE OTHER OF THE MAN IN OUR
NATIONAL HISTORIC SITE IN THE
OWENS VALLEY. UH I'VE I'VE SPENT
GOOD CHUNK OF TIME IN BOTH OF
THOSE SITES, AND THEY REALLY ARE
EXCELLENT MUSEUMS THAT TELL THE
STORY OF THIS, UH, THIS GRAVE
INJUSTICE AND THEY HAVE SOME
REALLY TOP NOTCH EDUCATORS AND
DOCENTS AND, UH UH, MUSEUM
PROFESSIONALS WHO HAVE HELPED TO
MAKE NOT ONLY THE HIS, THE
HISTORY COME ALIVE BUT REALLY
FORCE THE VISITOR TO GRAPPLE
WITH THE CONTEMPORARY CHALLENGES
, UH AND CONUNDRUM THAT HAVE
BEEN THAT ARE RAISED BY THIS
THIS THIS DARK STORY, UH, ABOUT
MINORITY RIGHTS ABOUT DEMOCRACY
ABOUT, UH, PROTECTING, UH, THE
VULNERABLE AND SO, I. I JUST I
COMMEND THOSE TWO SITES TO YOU.
IF YOU HAVEN'T HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO UH, THE JAPANESE
AMERICAN NATIONAL MUSEUM AND
MAN'S AT OUR NATIONAL HISTORIC
SITE. UH, THEY REALLY DO AN
EXCELLENT JOB OF INTERPRETING
AND TELLING THIS DIFFICULT
STORY. NÓ FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SENATOR MIN YOU MAY
CONCLUDE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
I VOTE. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALL. UH, A ROGUE. AYE,
ARCHULETA. I ASHBY. I ATKINS I
BECKER HØI BLAKESPEAR. AYE,
BRADFORD. I CABALLERO. HØI
CORTEZ. AYE, DALLY. DODD. AYE,
I, EDWIN UH, GLASER. AYE.
GONZALES. I GROWTH. AYE, ORO. I
JONES AYE, LAIRD. AYE, LIMÓN. I
MAGUIRE. MINAR. AYE MIN. NEWMAN.
AYE. WHEN AYE. YOU LOVE. AYE,
BUT PINO. AYE, ROD. I RUBIO. I
SAY ART TO I. SKINNER. HIY SMALL
CUEVAS. I STERN. AYE, UMBERG. I
WILL HAVE AYE, WIENER. HØI WILL.
AYE. MILO. I 39 NÓ ZERO. THE, UM
AND THE MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK TO THE
THREE ITEMS THAT WERE PLACED ON
CALL WILL START WITH FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE, WHICH IS THE
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENT. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS.
AYE. SHAKESPEARE. AYE. NILO. PER
YEAR. AYE. I 39 NÓ ZERO. THE
APPOINTMENTS ARE CONFIRMED. FILE
ITEM NUMBER FIVE. AGAIN
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENT. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS
HØI. BLAKESPEAR AYE. NILO.
VIDEO. AYE. I 39 NÓ ZERO. THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED. MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN,
WHICH IS, UH S¼ B 263 BY SENATOR
DODD. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BLAKESPEAR AYE. THERE
ARE A. VIDEO. AYE. W. I 37 NÓ
ZERO. THE MEASURE IS ADOPTED. OR
THE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO RETURN TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. START
WITH THESE ARE THE ADJOURNED
MEMORIES. WE'LL START WITH
SENATOR OCHO. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS. IT IS WITH
GREAT SADNESS THAT I RISE TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF AMY HER WHO
PASSED AWAY LAST NOVEMBER AT THE
YOUNG AGE OF 56 FROM A BRAIN
TUMOR. BORN IN BANNING AMY WAS A
LIFELONG AND PASSIONATE RESIDENT
OF THE INLAND EMPIRE. SHE
GRADUATED FROM BANNING HIGH
SCHOOL IN 1985 SAT ON THE SCHOOL
BOARD FROM 2000 AND THREE TO
2011 AND WAS AN ACTIVE MEMBER OF
THE SAN GGO PAST HISTORICAL
SOCIETY ALONG WITH HER MOTHER.
IN 2008. SHE FOUND THAT THE BOYS
AND GIRLS CLUB OF SANGO PASS IN
HER LEADERSHIP. IN HER
LEADERSHIP ROLE AS èC E Ó. SHE
USED HER BOUNDLESS ENERGY AND
CREATIVITY TO SERVE THE
COMMUNITY AND POSITIVELY
MOTIVATE THE YOUTH.
TRANSFORMATIVE DEVOTED, FOCUSED
AND VERY LOVING. THESE ARE SOME
OF THE WORDS USED TO DESCRIBE
AMY BY THOSE WHO KNEW HER BEST.
HER OBITUARY SAYS IT PERFECTLY.
IN A WORD. AMY WAS ELECTRIC. SHE
HAD A ZEST FOR LO FOR HER LIFE
AND COMMUNITY THAT CANNOT AND
WILL NOT BE SURPASSED FOR YEARS
TO COME. IF EVER. SHE WAS A
PILLAR OF HOPE AND LIFE FOR
EVERYONE SHE CROSSED PATHS WITH
THERE IS NÓ AMOUNT OF WORDS TO
BE SAID THAT COULD EVER COME
CLOSE TO ENCOMPASSING THE PERSON
SHE WAS. AMY SURVIVED BY HER
HUSBAND, JOE, AND THREE KIDS,
RYAN, TROY, AND HANNAH, HER
MOTHER, KATHLEEN HOBART AND HER
BELOVED DOG BRIM. SHE WAS
PRECEDED IN DEATH BY HER FATHER,
FREMONT, HOBART. I WISH AMY'S
FAMILY AND MANY FRIENDS, PEACE
AND COMFORT DURING THIS TIME OF
DEEP SORROW. I WOULD BE HONORED
IF THIS BODY WOULD ADJOURN IN
HER MEMORY. THANK YOU. BEING HER
NAME FORWARD TO THE DESK SO THAT
SHE MAY BE APPROPRIATELY
MEMORIALIZED. SENATOR
BLAKESPEAR. THANK YOU. I RISE
TODAY TO PAY TRIBUTE TO MY
FRIEND AND CONSTITUENT JOANNE
HUBBARD, A RESIDENT OF CARDIFF
BY THE SEA WHO PASSED AWAY ON
DECEMBER 18TH AT AGE 88. IN
SPIRIT. I IMAGINE THAT JOANNE
SADDLED UP AND RODE HER BELOVED
TENNESSEE WALKER TRIGGER INTO
THE SUNSET TO JOIN HER TWO
BELOVED DAUGHTERS, JODY AND
SUSAN, WHO WERE TAKEN FAR TOO
SOON IN LIFE, AND HER LATE
HUSBAND, RICK. SITTING TALL IN
THE SADDLE, HER REGAL BEARING
AND EXTENSION OF HER NOBLE HORSE
, JOANNE CREATED A STRIKING
PRESENCE. SHE WILL FOREVER BE
REMEMBERED FOR HER LOVE OF
HORSES AND HER ADVOCACY FOR
TRAILS. JOANNE LEARNED TO RIDE
WHEN SHE WAS EIGHT YEARS OLD
AMONG THE APRICOT AND WALNUT
ORCHARDS THAT SURROUNDED HER
RURAL SAN FERNANDO VALLEY HOME.
BY THE TIME OF HER PASSING, THIS
LITTLE GIRL HAD GROWN UP OWNED
40 HORSES AND PRESERVED A LEGACY
OF OPEN TRAILS IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. WHEN SUBURBAN
HOUSING TRACTS BEGAN SPROUTING
UP AND ENCROACHING ON TRAILS,
JOANNE BECAME AN EARLY AND
LIFELONG TRAIL PERSON. SHE WAS
AN OUTSPOKEN AND PASSIONATE
ADVOCATE FOR PROTECTING TRAILS
THAT WERE BEING ERASED BY
DEVELOPMENT. JOANNE RESEARCHED
PROPERTY AND EASEMENTS. SHE
SPOKE TO CITY COUNCILS AND AT
COUNTY MEETINGS, AND SHE USUALLY
WON HER ARGUMENTS FOR RETAINING
AND MAINTAINING THE HORSE'S PART
FOR THE HORSE'S TRAIL FOR ALL TO
ENJOY. SHE MET HER FUTURE
HUSBAND, RICK, WHILE PLAYING
VOLLEYBALL ON THE BEACH AT AGE
15 BY AGE 18. THEY WERE MARRIED
AND STARTING A FAMILY IN
CALABASAS, A PARADISE FOR HORSE
LOVERS, WHICH SENATOR STERN, THE
SENATOR FROM LOS ANGELES KNOWS
VERY WELL. HER HUSBAND, RICK,
SHARED HER AVID INTEREST IN
TRAILS. HE WAS THE FOUNDING
PRESIDENT OF THE SANTA MONICA
MOUNTAINS TRAIL COUNCIL IN 1972,
AND FOR YEARS THEY WORKED
TOGETHER TO PRESERVE HISTORIC
TRAILS AND CREATE OTHERS THAT
NOW LINK LOCAL, STATE AND
FEDERAL PARKS THAT EXTEND FROM
GRIFFITH PARK IN LOS ANGELES TO
POINT MAGU IN VENTURA COUNTY.
WHEN JOANNE MOVED TO ENCINITAS,
SHE JOINED THE SAN TO GUIDO
RIDERS AND BECAME A FOUNDING
MEMBER OF THE ENCINITAS TRAILS
COALITION WORKING WITH THE CITY
TO DEVELOP THE RECREATIONAL
TRAILS, MASTER PLAN. THANKS IN
GREAT PART TO JOANNE'S EFFORTS,
RESIDENTS ENJOY MILES OF TRAILS
THAT CRISSCROSS THE CITY FOR ALL
TO ENJOY RIDING, CYCLING,
HIKING, RUNNING AND JUST
WANDERING. IT WAS MY HONOR TO
SERVE ALONGSIDE HER DAUGHTER,
JODY, WHO WAS A CYCLIST AND BODY
SURFER, AND SHE CHAMPIONED THE
TRAILS PLAN WHEN SHE SERVED ON
THE ENCINITAS CITY COUNCIL.
COMMEMORATIVE BENCHES AT SWAMI'S
HONOR, JOANNE AND JODY, WITH
INSCRIPTIONS THAT READ TRAILS
ARE FOR EVERYONE AND WAVES ARE
FOR EVERYONE SOON. A
COMMEMORATIVE BOULDER ALONG THE
RANCHO SANTA FE TRAIL AND ALIEN
HEIM, A NEIGHBORHOOD OF
ENCINITAS, A COMMUNITY OF
ENSIGNS. EXCUSE ME WILL HONOR
JOANNE AS WELL. IT'S NOT
SURPRISING THAT JOANNE'S
DAUGHTER GREW UP TO BE A CIVIC
LEADER. JOANNE WAS A CHAMPION
FOR WOMEN'S RIGHTS AND WAS
ACTIVELY ENGAGED IN PROGRESSIVE
POLITICS. SHE INSPIRED OTHERS
WITH HER ENERGETIC PERSONALITY,
HER POSITIVE PERSISTENCE AND HER
FOR PERSUASION. JOANNE NEVER
GAVE UP. EVEN AT AGE 88. JOANNE
WAS ALWAYS READY TO GO. SHE
CONTINUED TO RIDE TRIGGER HER
HORSE. SHE VALUED VISITS FROM
HER GRANDSON, JACK. SHE ENJOYED
OUTINGS WITH HER LADIES WHO
LUNCH AND ATTENDING PLAYS AT
LOCAL THEATERS. SHE EVEN SNUCK
IN A THEATER TRIP TO NEW YORK
CITY. JUST LAST YEAR UNTIL THE
END, JOANNE SAID, YES TO LIFE,
SHE WILL BE LOVINGLY REMEMBERED
AND SORELY MISSED BY ALL. THANK
YOU. PLEASE BRING HER NAME
FORWARD TO THE DESK SO SHE MAY
BE APPROPRIATELY MEMORIALIZED AS
WELL. SENATOR MIN. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. MEMBERS I RISE
TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF DÂN
BURKE, A PROFESSOR AND FORMER
COLLEAGUE OF MINE AT U, èC,
IRVINE SCHOOL OF LAW. DÂN WAS A
GIANT IN THE FIELD OF LAW AND
TECHNOLOGY, AND HE WAS A
FOUNDING MEMBER OF THE U èC I
SCHOOL OF LAW. AND THE FIRST
CHANCELLOR'S PROFESSOR AT THE
LAW SCHOOL. PROFESSOR BURKE WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN U èC. I LAW'S
FORMATION AND UNPRECEDENTED
SUCCESS. CURRENT U èC SCHOOL OF
LAW, DEAN AUSTIN PARISH SAID OF
HIM. DÂN WAS A BRILLIANT AND
REMARKABLE PROFESSOR. THROUGHOUT
HIS PROMINENT CAREER, HE
CONSISTENTLY RANKED AMONG THE
LEADING AND PIONEERING
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY SCHOLARS
IN THE AMERICAN LEO ACADEMY. AND
WAS AT THE FOREFRONT AROUND
ISSUES TOUCHING ON LAW
TECHNOLOGY, THE INTERNET AND A.
I AS THE FOUNDING MEMBER OF UC
IRVINE SCHOOL OF LAW FACULTY. HE
LEFT HIS MARK IN MANY, MANY WAYS
. HE WAS KNOWN FOR HIS KINDNESS
AND HIS MENTORSHIP AND HE WILL
BE INCREDIBLY MISSED BY HIS
COLLEAGUES. HIS PREMATURE
PASSING WAS A SAD MOMENT FOR OUR
PROFESSION AND OUR SCHOOL.
PROFESSOR BURKE RECEIVED MANY
HONORS, FELLOWSHIPS AND AWARDS
THROUGHOUT HIS CAREER. HE
RECEIVED TWO FULBRIGHT
SCHOLARSHIPS, CONDUCTING
GROUNDBREAKING RESEARCH TO STUDY
GERMAN AND EU BIOTECHNOLOGY
PATENTING AT THE MAX PLANCK
INSTITUTE FOR INNOVATION AND
COMPETITION IN MUNICH, THEN
LATER AS A FULBRIGHT
CYBERSECURITY SCHOLAR AT THE
OXFORD INTERNET INSTITUTE'S
DIGITAL ETHICS LAB IN THE UNITED
KINGDOM. IN 2015. HE WAS A
SELECTED FOR A LEVER LEVER HOME
SCHOLARSHIP, OUR VISITOR SHIP TO
THE LONDON SCHOOL OF ECONOMICS
AND POLITICAL SCIENCE. THAT SAME
YEAR, HE WON THE IP VANGUARD
AWARD BY THE CALIFORNIA STATE
BAR SECTION ON INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY. IN 2019. HE'S A SENIOR
VISITING SCHOLAR AT THE
WEIZENBAUM INSTITUTE FOR THE
NETWORK SOCIETY IN BERLIN. BUT I
THINK HOW PROFESSOR BURKE WILL
BE REMEMBERED MOST IS NOT FOR
HIS SIGNIFICANT ACCOMPLISHMENTS
IN HIS FIELD, BUT RATHER FOR HIS
DEDICATION, HARD WORK AND
COMMITMENT AS A FRIEND AS A
MENTOR AND AS A TEACHER. MY WIFE
ACTUALLY HAS SAT IN THE OFFICE
NEXT TO HIM FOR 11 YEARS. UH AT
U èC I LAW AND SHE PERSONALLY
ATTESTED TO ME JUST HOW MANY
COUNTLESS STUDENTS HE MENTORED
OVER THE YEARS. HE WAS A POPULAR
PROFESSOR KNOWN FOR HIS DRY WIT
AND, UH, HE CONSISTENTLY
RECEIVED TOP REVIEWS FROM
STUDENTS. UH, AND COUNTLESS
NUMBERS OF PROFESSORS, YOUNGER
PROFESSORS HAVE ATTESTED TO HIS
MENTORSHIP OF THEM. HIS HIS DEEP
INTEREST AND PASSION AND HARD
WORK AND TRYING TO ADVANCE THEIR
CAREERS AS WELL. HE WAS A FUNNY
GUY WHO OFTEN WOULD TELL PEOPLE
THEY WERE WRONG, INCLUDING ME,
AND PROBABLY MY WIFE, AND HE WAS
KNOWN TO TYPICALLY SAY YOU'RE
WRONG, BUT IN A VERY INTERESTING
WAY, WHICH IS ONE OF HIS
TRADEMARKS. SO I JUST WANNA
CLOSE WITH, UH, THE COMMENTS HE
MADE BEFORE HIS PASSING. AND MAY
WE ALL LIVE LIFE LIKE THIS, HE
SAID. I HAVE NÓ SERIOUS REGRETS.
I'VE HAD A FANTASTIC MARRIAGE
FOR 36 YEARS, MY CAREER HAS GONE
FAR BETTER THAN ANYONE WOULD
HAVE IMAGINED. I'VE HAD AMAZING
OPPORTUNITIES AND EXPERIENCES I
COULDN'T HAVE FORESEEN. I'VE
USED UP FAR MORE THAN MY SHARE
OF THE PLANET'S RESEARCH
RESOURCES. I'VE ENGAGED WITH
AMAZING COLLEAGUES AND
COLLABORATORS. IT'S ALL GOOD. I
ASKED THE SENATE JOIN ME TODAY
IN OFFERING OUR MOST SINCERE
CONDOLENCES TO HIS WIFE, LAURIE,
HIS DAUGHTER, RAIN HIS FAMILY
MEMBERS, FRIENDS, COLLEAGUES AND
STUDENTS AND ASKED THAT WE
ADJOURN HIS MEMORY. IT'S ALL
GOOD. THANK YOU. SENATOR PLEASE
BRING HIS NAME FORWARD TO THE
DESK SO THAT HE MAY BE
APPROPRIATELY MEMORIALIZED. IF
THERE IS NÓ OTHER BUSINESS,
SENATOR MAGUIRE THE DESK IS
CLEAR. THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS. THE NEXT
FLOOR SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR
THURSDAY, FEBRUARY 22ND AT 9
A.M. ENJOY THE WEEK. THE SENATE
WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL 330, AT
WHICH TIME THE ADJOURNMENT
MOTION WILL BE MADE. WE WILL
RECONVENE THURSDAY AT 9 A.M.